he's a Marvel nerd are you into Marvel
you know what no like my brother watches
them but I just can't get into anime
I think I think even I know it's not ah
yeah yeah she called it that Guns and
Roses oh my God and yeah I don't really
know about reggae
she said the anime my dude well how do
you must start
okay like you can't not like Marvel it's
amazing there's so many different things
and it's not anime it's just like a
bunch of superheroes who try to save
everybody
yeah I'll give it a chance you know
she's looking at her head she's looking
like what a [ __ ] loser
you can't not like Marvel no I'm gonna
say this I don't know if you guys
watching disagree with group but I'm
gonna say this and I'm making the hot
take the current iteration of Marvel
movies are [ __ ] trash I said it
I hate what this current iteration of
Marvel movies has done to the movie
industry itself listen they were already
for-profit but they have literally shot
this into the [ __ ] sky where again
redo spin-offs individual Marvel and
they are shitty scripts they are four
kids and I hate that I used to love
reading Marvel Comics and I thought they
were for adults not read Thor he's a
[ __ ] loser made for dad jokes and
moms to watch calmly like I hate Marvel
movies okay but I do love Marvel content
but right now if you ask me which I
prefer between two the people who I
think are making the best content is DC
I don't talk about the movie so I'm
talking about the cartoons DC makes them
fire ass superhero cartoons the best
so I want to see that all right because
when I meet Marvel fans and they're just
boating about like oh these movies like
they're trash 95 of these movies about
Marvel movies are garbage
I said we got off my chest I didn't ever
think we'd have a video where I could
say all this
I'm glad I did I agree I'm like the the
content of Marvel that I that consume is
the video games on the PS5 like the spot
and I said the video game it's not the
video games it's the Spider-Man video
games I believe they're well done very
well done but as far as movies
only the only Marvel movie that I really
enjoyed really enjoyed was the original
one
blade one
um
that's not what she did he rejected me
because he's a [ __ ] loser
loser that nerd can be cute no not the
way
you [ __ ] look
you should have walked in there and said
this guy's a DND fine
he said he's a [ __ ] with the same
thing no to her it's the same thing
maybe to her but it doesn't mean the
same thing socially if I go into a room
and say oh yo the girl's a nerd a lot of
guys want to like that a lot of women
are gonna like that there's gonna be
plenty of people when you say the purse
a girl being a nerd and a guy being a
nerd is not the same level of nerd
if a girl if a guy walks he's got this
girl is a nerd oh okay if a girl walks
in that place the place pack up full of
girls and she says this guy's a nerd
that's not good that's not they don't
think it's cute you're wrong okay you're
absolutely wrong and you know what
there's gonna be a bunch of women in the
comments right now saying I love nerds
in fact being a nerd is trendy it is the
new way of being in right now you think
I'm wrong you guys leave us know in the
comments which one do you give me a
preacher let us know I'm Donnie I'm Mia
nice to meet you nice to meet you so
tell me about you what do you do I grew
up in California moved here six years
ago I have a fun fact
you got that she's like yo you familiar
with this superhero she was trying to be
the Flash
favorite Marvel movie character anything
like that Spider-Man
you're absolutely lovely
don't don't don't don't
the the the [ __ ] we saw the jab we hey
no we saw that twitch no ma'am we don't
need to hear it don't
don't do it down don't do it I'm done
I'm being nice to meet you yeah nice to
meet you so what do you like to do for
fun I love going out and like exploring
trying to find out new places and things
like that but like 90 of the time I'm at
home knitting with my dog I love dogs I
have a dog myself oh what type of dog do
you have uh he's like a mini golden
doodle so he's like yeah very fluffy
like looks exactly like a teddy bear
Doodles are so cute I love doodles
ah I'm sorry I don't love you
toodaloo
yeah you know the best part about the
bunny
[Music]
well I mean there's just something so
fascinating at watching how much people
can put up a a fake face and have these
conversations like they can't wait to
get rid of the other person you're just
not my type like I think you're you're
beautiful but what's your type uh
probably like Asian girls yeah what's
your type uh my people my [ __ ]
people
we keep it in the culture you dig no
interracial no race mixing no confusion
no hybrids no delineation we keep it
pure
you're Chinese right yay so why were you
dating Korean oh shut the [ __ ] up
King Kong Consciousness there will be no
snow Buddy season this year
I see you my brother and I could see the
self-hatred you chose a white woman for
one reason and one reason only is
because deep down inside you haven't
gone over the psychological slavery that
the white man has put you through and
that's why you covered his woman because
you think that if you are with his woman
you will be like the white man but guess
what brother
those shackles they're fast and tight
and when the revolution comes us
pan-african Brothers won't be with you
because we're going to understand you
not for us you afford them because the
biggest show of commitment that a man
can make to the black cause is to marry
a black woman
all that is very long for what's your
type [ __ ]
oh why do you have a racial preference I
think there's just like is that the
cultural disconnect that's kind of hard
to get over totally valid lovely to meet
you no you're great Sam Sam Don nice to
meet you
foreign
they did this [ __ ] dirty
you said you like Asians how about a
weeb I just hope he looks like he says
so
how do you feel about tentacles like I
just feel like I'll be like for her
that's a question that works I like the
outfit thank you you can always dress
like this um I do cosplay often um it's
like I've been doing it for 10 years
it's cosplay a little bit of a sex thing
it's not something a sex thing for me
I've just never done it in Cosplay
before but it is a very popular thing
exactly
why did you press the button
um I'm just not that attracted to you
I'm sorry
sure thank you hi hi what's your name
I'm Christy how about you Christy
foreign
shout out to you the cut you brought on
an Asian girl like he requested
but guess what
she gonna Buzz him out yeah yeah buzz by
your own yes by your own you know all of
a sudden you decide listen I'm only go
for these black women then these black
women reject you all the time you know
what I'm saying sometimes I happen like
that that was so you started not to be
mad cause you got a little white girl or
whatever like another one you know what
I'm saying that happens sometimes
you're still a [ __ ] race Trader
yeah so you feel targeted I'm talking to
you okay King Kong Consciousness in the
building
I see you and I see those shackles
so what do you do for fun I love sports
basketball volleyball tennis or like the
three that I mainly play okay
um but I'll play anything it's because
uh sorry no worries uh yeah why'd you
pass it I feel like we have like good
like friend Vibes have you been failing
kind of nervous like I don't know if you
can tell but my lip is quivering because
I can't like contain I can't contain my
nervousness nice to meet you I'm Christy
this is mile freak low-key every time I
see a girl with bangs all I want to do
is just raise the hood and be like what
you got here
you go like this
just to do that all right I was like oh
my God you a real estate agent cause the
land
all right let's go under my umbrella
[Laughter]
yeah oh [ __ ] oh but a reason I said girl
you make me feel so safe Rihanna
real estate okay Rihanna but she grew
into that forehead Rihanna being two
players at the same time forehead
Barbados wrestler from America I always
said Rihanna with that 4S you know
honorary Ethiopian
yeah
um so what do you like to do for
fun I like to hike Lomb or anything
outdoors like to serve from from
California so
[Music]
oh
I think he beat you to it can you beat
me okay I'm sorry I just didn't feel the
spark no I'm sorry yeah it's okay it's
okay have a good one all right this is
cringy
hi Amy I'm Alfred nice to meet you
Amy's celebrity crush is Joe Rogan yeah
you really like him yeah I don't know
why I think it's the testosterone I mean
I guess
he's alive yeah
um
I feel so bad oh my God why'd you press
the button it's just not my time I'm so
sorry
he said
we can make jokes about race but you
can't joke about the other stuff you
know
what toy
I mean I was just gonna say she might be
a Joe Rogan fan but she forgot the
fitness stuff
God damn he just like a look you can't
look you can you can't like a look of a
[ __ ] just say what it is
to see what it is
it's fine it's not a big deal well it is
you
threw yourself in that [ __ ] it's not a
big deal yeah it is hold up hold up hold
up hold up I won't ask this
we can make jokes about them not being
interested because a person's race
which they can't change
but if I make a joke about the fact that
they are interested because the person's
awake [ __ ] we just did but I'm
saying but you see the red tape you felt
right well
you went there I mean I wouldn't because
you you could do it across the line yeah
yeah make them but like you see that
it's interesting like the whole time you
have no reservation Asian uh black white
whatever we said it but that's what
happened with the other chick when
everybody was talking about oh yeah he
got this and that yeah whenever whenever
people were talking oh yeah he's fat
shaming her because you hugged her and
then after that
uh yeah you rejected her but the first
thing she said is like yeah Asian I like
Asians yeah so so he she could say that
she can fetishize them for their
asianness
hey I'm Anna I'm Alfred nice to meet you
me too Alfred wants a lot of kids you
want a lot of kids like how many I don't
know what a lot of kids is
um I want like four eventually that's
kind of a lot what about you I don't
want kids no maybe not at all I'm so
sorry
the way he said it none at all okay
she should look like an elf He buzzed
the elf out you know what's funny is
people are gonna get mad at him in the
back room because he was because I
didn't want kids but yes you want kids
you should Buzz them because they don't
want you yes it doesn't make you yes yes
don't wait it's nobody's time if someone
wants kid you don't want kid it's not
gonna work don't try to [ __ ] work it
out no no no no no no no no no no what's
your dating Adrian's oh well I'm 36. six
I would say like 28 to 28 40. what's
yours am I an old lady I'm an old lady
this [ __ ] never missed
shank sank sank sank sank they're not
even trying no they're not trying oh
Lord
what are you looking for in a partner
um I'm looking for someone who can talk
to me you know it could be real yeah you
know someone who likes Adventure not
just stay in even though I do like
staying in sometimes but oh just not my
type I'm sorry like what is your type
Latinas
you don't did it outside of Latinas that
seemed cringy that is not what I meant
they're gonna think I'm an [ __ ]
Twitter's gonna drag the [ __ ] out of him
for that one he said Latinas
a big one was probably Latina they found
what kind of Latina the Asian guy was
like I only did my own because of
cultural thing this man said Latinos
[Music]
how are you hi I'm good how are you
Laura hi nice to meet you what's your
take Alfred I'm looking for someone who
knows who they want in life someone
who's confident
when no one's all right what's the top
Latinas big titties as soon as I go for
someone that I can just drive and Vibe
with someone I could get to know and
have my family with someone I could
someone I could someone that could me
because I want to attend them you feel
me there's a way that we can interweave
a sense of connection girl we're gonna
build this Detention Center where we're
gonna get locked up talk about shacked
up talk about booed up the [ __ ] boy came
out quick let's carry on Independent
okay but you also said something else
Athena
okay
what about you I like a man who has a
[ __ ] together
it's held
I mean I'm Latina
hi I'm Laura I'm sorry I'm out of breath
I'm just playing ping pong oh nice
uh how's your experience been good
good I I mean
well what's this guy be like bro I got
[ __ ] to do what the [ __ ] am I doing here
yeah yeah
what are you doing good
this is my first time doing this but the
girls oh that's a good question how was
that how was walking into a sorority a
woman all Juiced up on whatever you know
and how did you establish yourself in
the hierarchy
she's like what the [ __ ] is this this
guy some kind of social scientist what a
cringe Lord yeah yo please buzz him out
man
what kind of not like that's just like
inherent
ly I don't know I'm a friendly person
and I'm really like this yeah same for
you you seem just like super down to
earth Laura has a serious shopping
addiction to kind of clean that up I'm a
wardrobe stylist so I'm always on the
lookout for shopping and for things and
if it sounds productive Jesse what is
addicted to nicotine patches well so
people don't know nicotine is a
neurotropic
um so I know Tropics is something that
helps um your brain be good
I think it's dangerous to be in a sober
state for too long for me interesting
what do you do for work run a company oh
so you have a lot more freedom where you
can all right yeah find each other
attractive I do find you attractive I
find you attractive too you think you
want to go on a second date I mean I
would like to go on the second date I
would all right I'm gonna light up one
more all right
and then you know what's gonna happen
he's gonna turn her and he's she's gonna
work for him and this big ass company
they're going to do webcam [ __ ] is that
that's what I feel I would I just feel
so cringy when I do this
yeah I'd like that for sure
I was just feeling the vibe so there's
just something about the way that we're
communicating I'm digging it you're
digging it too good
I could do this but on the inside I'm
dying because I'm like you [ __ ] lose
but on the outside I'm like what are you
doing exactly I don't know we about to
[ __ ] chill bro
because I'm making eye contact and I
know she looking and she digging it you
know I mean I'm speaking in a bit of a
lower tone I'm slowing down
you want to go yeah I'm definitely down
I'd love to see you again absolutely let
me get your number
no no we can talk of that we'll figure
out the details I'll plan today you know
I like to take control a little bit
oh
you're good yeah yeah
I came but you're good but you good at
it yeah I mean you talk to ladies you
just realized and you know what I found
out
I don't care enough to get laid to do
all that so I'm like this women find out
I'll be telling I like D I like dozen
dragons I like anime I like all this
[ __ ] I don't care if you like it or you
don't you don't need to participate no
you don't I like going out dancing
you're not invited man these are for me
I am what I am
I'm not gonna but I understand the
efficiency of being like that
because it's home this one right here I
understand I get it I know why the
ladies like it and I can talk like this
sometimes I pick up the phone like good
day hello yes God
I can do all that but I'd rather just
chill out relax
so
that's what I was thinking when I was
listening this guy what'd you think
it's cool shooter
you like school shooter school shooter
God damn
all right let's find out if he accepts a
dick all right I'm gonna light up one
more time and if you don't press me you
will win the button and you turn on
second date no suppress it press it do
it for the content
[Music]
I'm sorry sorry sorry
I think I I had I had the second I had
the second guess you said you're going I
I certainly I certainly uh would yeah I
think I I would
I think you're great um but
you just rejected it yeah I went with my
guts school shooter she does one I don't
even I think it's just High
on something else yo the way he's moving
about it man so it has to be a very
strong overwhelming yes otherwise I
catch myself and then I I'll default to
now
I'm an insane person I think I that was
the right choice that he made to be
honest all right
she said I think he's crazy
yes I don't know
game time body
functions I feel so bad she was so sweet
this [ __ ] is hot yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah let me just say this uh don't trust
any man with nail polish I'm just like
set it set it before do it again
just know that's all I got anything else
you want to say it's cool shooter all
right let us know what you guys think in
the comments we want to hear from you